how are you doing today sir i am doing
excellent
today um first of all thank you for
coming in uh to chat and talk and what's
funny is normally
when i sit down with someone it's like
one thing that i want to talk about like
baby driver
right but with you there's like a resume
that goes back
many many years and with you doing a lot
of different facets of the industry
so i want to jump into a whole bunch of
stuff which is let's start at the
beginning uh
you got started with doing is it stunt
work so
how did you how did you get that break
to get on like a big hollywood movie
so when i was a kid my parents took me
to the drive-in
i grew up in massachusetts oh i did too
where uh near foxborough
no way yeah patriots fan yeah of course
okay
i'm not right well then you consider the
exit is over there
this that concludes this
um right on no i grew up massachusetts
my parents took me to the drive-in and
took me to see a movie called hooper
which was i just i saw that i think i
was 10 years old and i was like
that's it that's the coolest thing ever
and so from then on i wanted to be a
stunt man so when i graduated high
school i moved out to california
i actually went to new york first to try
to make a go of it there and then
you know there was always kind of that
feeling that if you're going to be a
stunt man you got to be a hollywood
stunt man
so i moved to california and did what
they used to call hustling
to where you'd show up we'd go down to
the film permit office
and find out who pulled permits and then
we would take our thomas guide remember
the thomas guide i do
and we'd take the thomas guide and we'd
go and find these films and we'd sneak
on set and we'd look for the stunt
coordinator
and you'd show up with your headshot
with with no credits and know
anything on it you know and hand it to
him and say i want to be a stunt man and
for years you know three four years you
would do that and
and guys would be like yep okay and you
just you do it as much as you could and
then eventually somebody gives you the
opportunity
to do something silly like fall down on
the ground or you know some little stunt
that you can't screw up and if you
if you do that and if you if you don't
screw it up you might get another chance
and i ended up meeting a guy named lane
levitt
who at that time back in the early 90s
and before
was the guy in hollywood for innovating
stunts
with equipment and he had things like
air ramps and descenders and
and ratchets and all this stuff
and he had a place he still has it out
in canyon country and it's basically a
stunt compound
and i had had some to pay the bills in
new york i worked as a concert
rigger for like paul simon and i did all
these different like high rigging
for these companies and um he had found
out through a friend that i did this and
he was starting this
program and he called me up and said hey
do you want to come and
work at my place and you'll clean pads
you'll deliver equipment you'll do this
and that
and in return i'll bring you on to the
biggest
sets there are and you will meet the
stunt coordinator that way through
working
and i was like i'm in i'm i was like a
kid in a candy store he goes when you're
not
cleaning pads or doing stunt related
errands for me
he goes the whole place is yours to
train and there were like four or five
scott rogers and
eddie fiola there were these guys out
there who are already kind of embedded
in this program
and i was like are you are you kidding
me so we clean some pads and then we get
to do high falls we get to do russian
swing we get to ride dirt bikes we get
to hit air ramps he had trampoline he
had a rock climbing gym
it was just like i've arrived in heaven
and he brought me on the biggest shows
that he was doing all the schwarzenegger
movies my first big movie was a racer
and he brought me on that for the run
and it just he
that man single-handedly gave me the
biggest opportunity
in my career um what talk a little bit
about doing stunts
on a movie like that how much
preparation are you doing a lot of these
things like in that
practice facility that you're going to
be shooting on set like how much is it
figuring out
super in advance and you know sort of
rejigging it
on set when you deal with what's
actually there it's kind of
you know it depends on the project you
do a show like the matrix
you know and we are there for six months
ahead of time
to learn the choreography to to train
with keanu
to be there anytime county wants to go
through the choreography
so you've got six months in a in a
basically a bitchin warehouse with a gym
and masseuses and
dietitians and anything you could ever
want to work on these fights
and then you get on a different show you
know a lower budget show that basically
wants you to put the stuff together on
the day
so it's it's it's really show
specific sure you know and it's kind of
changed over the years
sort of if if they you know
nobody wants to they all want matrix
action or born car
chases but once they realize what that
took
as far as prep and training and things
like that then a lot of them go well we
we want that but we don't want yeah
there's there's another we don't want to
pay for it well i was going to say
there's an element of you get what you
pay for
yes you do and it's proven and i mean
and nowhere is it proven better than in
john wick
because to be able to sit back on those
beautiful and wick too to sit back on
those
wide beautiful frames and just let the
action play out
the only way you get away with that is
with you know an actor who's gonna train
for months um when you read the script
uh what is the first thing you're doing
and how much
is it in the script on some of these
movies where it describes the exact
action and how much is it
car chase ensues it's again it's film
specific so sometimes i get a script
that says
car chase ensues bar fight ensues and
it's director specific
as well some directors are going to
completely give you
the the car chase and say bring me a car
chase and
they won't see the locations they
completely trust in
that vision and and you know having you
take care of it
some directors are completely the other
way where they show up and they are very
specific with what they want you to do
and
there's a there's a car chase or a fight
written out beat for beat in the script
so as a second unit director
now i you know because you i look at it
differently than i did when i was a
stunt coordinator
and as a stunt man you don't get to read
the script you show up and somebody says
smash into that car and you do
you don't know why but um as a second
unit director i
i walk through the script um i look at
the action beats i see if they
if they make sense you know if they
choreographically if that's a word
if they make sense and
then i will start to envision how
i'm gonna shoot it i i look for a style
in meeting with the director you know
because every as a second unit director
you're shooting someone else's style
and you have to that's the only way to
be successful as a security director if
you go off and try to make your own
movie you're
you're done that's not what you're there
for you know so
through meetings with the director and
the script you try to find a tone and a
style and really get on board with
your main unit director's vision and
work it out through there it's so funny
because i think that in my opinion i
don't think enough second unit directors
and stunt people get the credit that
they deserve because everyone
it's everyone is focused on the main
director
and not realizing that the main director
is not in the nitty-gritty sometimes of
the action
you know maybe they're doing performance
but i just think there's a lot of
background
in the industry that maybe isn't known i
couldn't agree with you more and to take
it even one step
further i mean i was talking to somebody
about the the car
that comes out of the warehouse and wick
too that car that beautiful side jump
and people always want to know how i did
it how i did it
there were so many people that had to be
on point
to get that shot from the stunt driver
to the guy driving the the camera
vehicle the
edge arm to the guy operating the crane
in the edge arm to my dp
to everybody making that shot work and
then you add in that element of danger
to where if that mustang crashes into
that camera car
there's massive you know injury
potential so
i agree with you 100 there's so many
people involved in getting stuff done
that
don't get the credit that they deserve
no absolutely i actually think that
i don't know if we could i don't know if
the academy awards would ever get there
but i do think that
best action sequence of the year uh
should be something
that is talked about because the level
of profession like
the amount of professionals that have to
pull something like that off and
the amount of money it costs and the
amount of time it's just something to
think about
i i think so too i i think i find it i
always find it amusing when we watch
the the oscars and the you know they'll
do the teasers to the films that are
coming up and they'll use a bunch of
action in those teasers
yeah okay we're just gonna all ignore
this okay cool yeah well it's just you
know what you know what it is i think
that there's an unwritten rule that the
that the director sort of gets all the
credit but i mean i
i don't want to mention a film but i was
on a very big
movie set and uh watching that the
director who everyone knows
directing the actors talking in a very
dialogue heavy moment on first unit
and then we walked down the other side
of the warehouse whatever
and the second unit was going and they
were filming a massive action set piece
with these other actors
where the main director was nowhere to
be found you know
just saying it you know it's case by
case for sure and
and ideally you know and perfect example
is
is a john wick or a baby driver to where
it's such a collaborative process you
know and
you're constantly all working together
and i think if there's
success in a film like that it's success
for the
for the entire crew you know it came
together because everybody was on point
absolutely i want to jump backwards uh
you did stunts or designed some stunts
on jackass and jackass too
i did i actually have a i just saw this
the other day i have a writing credit
for
for uh writing some of the uh what do
you call them like the scenes
sure so which which scene are you most
proud of in jackasses
we did i'll give you a little bit of
history on this we when we were on
spider-man 2
we were all huge fans of jackass and we
knew johnny from the first jackass and i
don't remember if we did
i think dukes came after spider-man 2
but already already big fans of it so
now we've got a bunch of stunt guys on
spider-man 2 and we're bored in between
choreographing fights and things like
this so we start to make our own jackass
so what we did we had a guy on the team
named beavis because he looked like
beavis
and we hung sandbags from the perms on
the stage
like 30 pound sandbags all in a row from
ropes
and we put beavis with a hockey helmet
on on a mountain bike and told him to
ride from this point to that point
through the sandbag gauntlet
and all the stunt guys pulled these
30-pound sandbags back
and they were all at different heights
and we just told him to ride and we said
you have to ride through and we
and he rode through and i think the
first sandbag hit his wheel and the
second one hit him in the head and
spun him like a helicopter knocked him
out cold
brought and we filmed it all and uh i i
think we ended up showing
i don't know if we showed spike or jeff
tremaine or johnny or whoever we'd show
them these clips and they're like that's
awesome
so in jackass too when they're in the
skate park and there's sandbags and they
have to ride through all these sandbags
that was a
sequence that i came up with from
something we had done on spider-man 2.
do you think uh i the jackass movies
always made me laugh
i mean hard i love them so do you think
that the jackass series is dead
or do you think that it could still come
back
or maybe with a new crew how do i say
this i
i love the jackass series i love those
johnny's such a great dude i hope
that they don't come back just because
the level
that those guys need to go to
is is scary sure you know and i don't
want to see those guys get hurt
they're getting older now well there's
that i don't know that knoxville feels
anything but he would do stuff
i mean he would just [ __ ] himself
and then come back and go did that look
good and you're like yeah dude it looked
good and bad all of the same he's like
no and he'd look at it because no no
it's got to hit harder and i'm like no
dude you don't need
don't do that stunt coordinating on a
jackass movie is probably the worst job
you could have ever because they don't
want a stunt coordinator you can't put a
pad in
you don't want to keep them safe they
don't want to be kept safe so you're
just kind of there to
set up yeah i i i re they really gave me
a lot of entertainment
yeah that's all i can say is thank you
great they're great and when he did when
he did dukes of hazzard and wanted to do
all his own stunts and
he's great he's super athletic and can
do his stuff and will certainly take the
hit but you you know to try and get
you know to tell johnny listen man if
you get hurt yeah the production shuts
down
yeah so you can i would plead with them
i'm like dude look at my kids they they
need a house you don't want me getting
fired come on man you'd be like
all right you know um you worked on
drive i did
right that movie is what i call a
masterpiece i [ __ ] love that film
so what did you do on drive and uh let's
talk about that
so on drive i was the stunt coordinator
and the second unit director
i worked with nicholas to design the car
chases
and shoot them some of the action parts
of them i mean we collaborated on it
um yeah it was it was amazing nicholas
is
brilliant um yet but also with that
movie he
that's a mixture of the visuals the
acting the script
uh but also the music the music and
which is going to go into another movie
but uh but the music and drive is
unbelievable yeah like the song choices
the use of purple
capturing la at the beginning the way he
photographs it
or maybe the way you photographed it who
knew no that opening car chase was all
all nicholas i mean he he always uh
referenced like like there was blood in
the water you know
and that he wanted a slow car chase and
in the beginning i was like i don't know
how that's going to work and then as we
started to
suss it out and i started to see his
vision and how he wanted to play it i
was like this is
really cool and the tension that he
built in that and uh
it was it was really cool it was a fun
it was a fun thing to shoot
you know well the other thing is that a
lot of people might not realize that was
not done for some mega budget
no that was like independently done all
around l.a
rinky dink in terms of budget you know
what i mean like band-aids and duct tape
yep
it was super low budget um not super low
budget it was a lower budget film
you know and everybody it's kind of
funny because people will reference that
car chase and i think we shot the pawn
shop car chase in
two days maybe something like that so we
were flying we didn't have a ton of
money and
you know we didn't have fast and furious
money for sure
we didn't even have fast money you know
that um i'm going gonna put myself in
this for a split second and i apologize
i did a set visit on that movie
and i was where christina hendricks was
leaning against the wall
at the pawn shop and i was there a
little bit and that's where i learned
about long lens paparazzi
because they were up on a hill shooting
through a car
and everyone was like it was just funny
because i didn't understand what was
going on they're like oh that's the
paparazzi i'm like they're all the way
up there how are they getting any shots
and then i came home that day from set
and they'd already had pictures online
of christina and everybody i'm like this
is unbelievable yeah how this works it's
crazy
you know it's crazy that movie it's
funny because a lot of people think that
that shot in the car chase with
over christina hendricks with the car
crashing behind her they think it was cg
or comp or something that was in camera
she was in the car
during the chase with that car
completely flat spinning
behind her and i think that look in her
face is
real like i think she was truly like
holy [ __ ] wearing a car chase here oh
yeah she's going for it she's going for
it it's such a great
it's cool um let's jump into what i call
captain america civil war
yeah what'd you do on that so i came in
uh
and directed second unit for not that
long
we were chad and dave were both there
directing second unit well i was gonna
say
they did if i'm not chad and dave were
talking about uh the masters of john
wick
uh i think in 87 11. um i believe they
did the opening set piece with
crossbones or am i wrong i'm not sure
what sequences they did um
but i know that they were on it and then
they
couldn't come back for some other stuff
so i was the
the guy the next guy yeah sorry
no no it's okay but i basically showed
up i mean i got a call and they said hey
can you come in and
help us out and i knew the russos before
um
and came in and had no script didn't
know anything about the movie
landed and they're like alright you're
gonna shoot chris evans over here and
he's fighting spider-man i'm like why is
he fighting spider-man they're like
don't
don't worry about it i was like okay and
then you're going up and chris was
looking at me like who are you and why
are you talking to me and
you know then the next thing is scarlett
kicking some dude in the head and then
there's a water tank thing with
sebastian and you're just cons
you know it was it was a lot of um i
don't say clean up but it was a lot of
you know just picking stuff up it was
towards the end of the shoot and
we did some fight stuff we did the
elevator shaft fall and just it was oh
yeah that's real good bouncing from set
to
set to set so what's funny is you you
you make it sound like you know it's all
last minute but that movie is so so
great yeah it doesn't it doesn't make
sense how good that movie is
no it was great and i think my stuff was
last minute because i came in towards
the end of the
shoot to just try and help tighten some
stuff up
sure awesome stuff so i was also gonna
say everyone by the end of the shoot is
just exhausted
yeah so you're like the fresh energy
except the russos man those dudes are
they're they don't run out of energy
well that's because one of them shuts
off and the other one starts back up
it's amazing right i would love to have
that it's crazy
they're non-stop those guys let's talk a
little bit about baby driver and
what is it like directing to music
um so baby driver when i first went in
and met with edgar wright
uh and he told me what we were doing
with this film
i my first thought was that's the
greatest idea
i've ever heard and then i was like why
didn't i think of this because it's
amazing
um and then was just like let's then i
think my second thought was
how are we going to do this you know
because you can choreograph fights
or things like that that are containable
to music you know like i can have you
walk across this room to
to whatever and throw a kick and throw a
dude it's easy because if it doesn't
work i can back you up and we can
we know that this is what we're dealing
with with car stuff
the you don't normally have the luxury
and on baby driver we didn't have the
luxury because we weren't a massive
budget film
so we didn't have the luxury of going
out onto these locations and
actually doing the stunt on the location
to time it out to make sure it fit with
the music
so we had to get creative and edgar
edgar when i came on board and started
this film edgar already had animatics he
had boards he had
all of this stuff ready to go which was
amazing he was
the most prepped director i've ever
worked with that's a big statement
he's he and there is a reason for every
single frame
in his boards i mean it's it's truly
impressive but he's
so prepared and i think you know i think
i've read somewhere and i think he might
have told me that he's been working on
this for
15 or a long time a long time so he's
thought about it a lot
um you know so he had animatics for
these car chases
and they were great and they were
certainly a
super solid foundation to start from
but there's you know in an animatic a
car can drift a corner and it takes four
seconds or whatever the artists
made it do in reality that car is going
to take 12 seconds or 15 seconds
so now because you're a slave to the
music you have to find out where to gain
those other eight or nine seconds right
because you you have to stay within the
confines of this song
and i think i wish when i was younger
and i think it should be a film school
class
to go out and take a popular song and
choreograph
any bit of action to it choreograph a
car chase or a fight scene or a
foot chase or something like that to it
because you have to be so
tight with your edit and with car stuff
you want to
you know you want to be in the beauty of
the the drift you don't want
to be you know in the suck part of the
drift because you're driven by the song
so it you start to really try and figure
out
where it all fits and it's it was
awesome it was amazing
what's amazing about baby driver is and
a lot of people might not realize that
a lot of the in fact almost all the
action or i think all the action
is during the daytime yeah and like you
look at john wick a lot of that is at
night
you know and doing that stuff during the
day is a challenge especially when you
have the real actors
in these scenes and for closures i mean
because
you know we a lot of times we do car
chases at night just because that's when
we can get the streets
that's right they're not busy so but it
was really important to edgar to shoot
atlanta for atlanta and to kind of
feature it as atlanta which i think he
did a great job and i think shooting it
during the day
just gives it a more you know it gives
it more of that 70s kind of feel
to it the to live and die in la the
bullet the french connection all these
car chases that were shot in the daytime
and stuff i think it was kind of nice it
added
certainly added a nostalgia to it you've
worked with
a lot of actors i think that keanu
reeves is known as one of the best in
terms of doing
action because uh that's why he gets to
do those wide shots
because you're not cheating it that's
right you know so besides keanu who is
a legend uh who are some of the other
actors that have really impressed you
in terms of their ability um to do
action yeah
um matt damon is top of the list he's
he's incredibly coachable he's
super athletic and just brings that same
attitude to training you know he wants
to
to be good he understands the benefit of
him
being able to do this stuff so his fight
training his driving
all of that stuff is really important to
him
and he really brings a solid work ethic
to it
you know there are actors that will come
in and they'll they'll put in their time
if you say hey man i gotta
you know i need you in fight training
for from one to two they'll come in at 1
110. it'll be there 150 maybe
sure a few instagrams in between and all
that and then you get the guys like matt
who will come in
at if you need him there at one he's
there at 12 30. he's warming up he's
there till two and then he's asking when
we can do it again and so
matt's huge ryan was amazing on drive
unbelievable his driving was incredible
and he was he was really really good at
it same thing
you know same that same work ethic
follows all those guys
keanu matt ryan ansel did a great job
where they're there to it's not a it's
not something they have to go to it's
something that they realize
how important it is and it allows us to
shoot them
sure doing the stuff i want to jump into
uh because i know we're running out of
time i want to jump into
black panther which you worked on um i
saw a
number of clips from it and i've seen a
bunch of footage from it
and it really looks awesome just looks
so
so good so what was the experience like
uh working on it
um the black panther experience was
amazing i mean first off ryan coogler is
unbelievable he's so tired he's
the things that are gonna come from that
man as a filmmaker are gonna blow
everybody away i mean
from black panther and whatever he does
next his his
style his ability to tell story and
understand character and
it's unbelievable i mean he's amazing
and
zero the man does have an ounce of ego
he's so approachable and i mean you're
he he sets this atmosphere where
everyone can be creative
and come to him and say hey man what
about this or how about that and
he knows exactly what he wants
but he still will listen to other
people's ideas and and filter through
what what works best for the project um
with uh panther for us on second unit
i think it was you know it's got to be
hard for a main unit director to hand
off
a massive chunk of the film like this
car chase and i know ryan
i don't think it had a second unit
before or not a big second unit
so there's always that bit of
apprehension
you know and you have to go in and meet
with them in it and try and assure them
that you're shooting their vision not my
vision
and with ryan we went we did a lot of
animatics we did like
i think 30 versions of animatics and
they weren't because
a lot of it was because we had locations
we lost locations we had x amount of
days and then we had to do it in
fewer days or whatever so we were
constantly reconfiguring the car chase
but
i mean for him we were on the other side
of the world
in south korea i was just gonna say you
did the south korea chase yeah we did
all the south korea chase just as a
stand-alone second unit and uh
you know i think it's nerve-wracking for
the main unit director because you're
just
waiting for footage back well i'm
curious uh there's been a lot of
great car chases i also look at the nick
fury chase
in that civil war and that to me that
chase is amazing
um so what does the chase that black
panther have maybe
how does it compare to some of the other
marvel chases or other movies in general
well i think black panther to me was one
of my favorite characters even before i
got
to black panther i think that his story
uh there's a lot of heart
in the black panther chase there's
there's his motivation
for why he's chasing these bad guys is
heartfelt and
who he's chasing with and and the
decisions he has to make
during this chase and how they affect
his life and how they affect his people
because he's the
leader of wakanda make that chase
a bit more um
deeper i think there's a deeper
motivation
for that chase so i think that's what's
going to make this a little there's more
story to this chase which is a testament
to ryan coogler
i was going to say character motivation
is everything yep um
you leave we're filming this right now
but in a few days you leave for
some vancouver place yeah to do some
deadpool movie
yeah it's just i don't know what this
deadpool thing's all about there's
apparently there's some hype around it i
know there's something right i guess the
first one did pretty good
it made a little bit of money yeah how
did you go after that movie or did david
call you and say
hey so i
for whatever reason had the great
fortune
of very early in my career when i was a
stunt guy meeting
two other stunt guys named dave leach
and chad stahlelski
and we ended up doing the matrixes
together and working together
and just having fun for
20 years as stunt guys and we all kind
of progressed in our careers to
coordinate and to secure direct and and
kind of went our own paths because
you know there's not usually two stunt
coordinators on a film we all had our
own thing
but we all kept in touch and we all kept
helping each other and stuff like that
and then dave and chad got john wick and
just absolutely crushed it and now the
two of them
are doing their own thing respectively
and crushing it
and i mean with john wick 2 atomic
blonde's going to be phenomenal
and so i'm basically just following
these two
as a second unit director and have the
great fortune of working with some of my
best friends and it's
i mean it's it's so
freeing because i mean i literally grew
up with these guys
so i can just walk in to the director's
office and be like hey man so what's the
deal with this and why are we here and
what and how many days and i'd
and you know there's no like eggshell
sort of aussie worried about what i
sure so it's it's great um
dave asked me to come on as the second
unit director to help shoot some of the
stuff
and i just think it's because we you
know we trust each other
or he trusts me i don't need to trust
him he's the main director
but uh i think he trusts me and he knows
that i'll i'll
i'll do the absolute best i can for him
and shoot his vision and sure
well uh i know that everything is
closely guarded secret on deadpool 2
but uh i'm assuming you've read the
script were you super happy
is there a sequence you're already like
chomping at the bit to film
so i thought the first deadpool was one
of the greatest films ever
i love anything that upsets
the the norm and i thought that film
came out and just
kind of made fun of a lot of other films
and
loved it so when i heard they were doing
deadpool 2 i was
ecstatic and then when i heard dave
leach was directing it i was even more
blown up
there couldn't be a better guy to direct
it his sensibilities are
perfect for this film there are
there are so many sequences that i'm
excited about and there's one in
particular that second unit is going to
have a big hand in that i
can't speak of but it's going to be
super cool well
it's going to be amazing well let's be
honest though david and chad are both
known
as action guys so in my opinion when you
bring david on to this project after tim
miller
you're basically saying we're getting
serious or we're very serious about the
action
you know and because the first one has
good action but it's not like um
like a born movie if you will you know
it's a different thing yeah
you know um do you think that the sequel
has a lot more action in it
um there's gonna be a lot of action in
the scene
i like that smile there's going to be a
lot of action okay i'm going to leave it
there because i don't want to get you in
trouble but how long are you working on
it
is it uh i'm going out for a couple
months oh so yeah i got it um but more
than all this so this might be one of
your last gigs doing
second unit for a little while oh man
from your mouth to god's ears i'm just
saying because you're getting ready to
direct your first feature yeah
so um talk a little bit about what this
project is what it's about and
how long you've been chasing trying to
do this sure so
i'm going to direct a movie called snow
ponies that gerard butler is going to
star in
it's a script that pat healy wrote god
like 10 years ago it was on the
blacklist
it's an amazing script it's a western
but a really kind of offbeat left of
center
western it's weird and unique and hyper
stylized and
and really really fun so we should start
shooting that in january i think
who's going to be your second unit
director or are you going to do first
and second
i will do first and second are you
really yeah so you're not screwing
around no i don't trust any security
directors those guys are hacks
no it's it's not um it's funny oddly
enough it's an ensemble character piece
there's not
a ton of action in it there's a there's
some shootouts but
we will i know these guys at 87 11.
i've heard of that company yeah they're
pretty good they're getting their fight
stuff together i think they're starting
to get a good handle on it so
i'm gonna uh pull some strings and uh
and get over there and and choreograph
all my fights and shootouts and stuff
and pre-vision before i go
so what i was gonna say though cause
you're they're gonna be wrapped on i
would imagine the 8711 guys are going to
also be working deadpool 2.
so i would imagine that's all going to
be wrapped by the time you're shooting
yeah
well and you know maybe chad or david
i'd let chatter dave shoot my second
unit so
that'd be kind of amazing right if you
uh got either of them
i know to work on this and i think you
should i absolutely think they should i
think that they owe you at least
that's what i'm saying yeah you should
call that card you know what i mean
just throw it out there but so you have
gerard uh
is it like a two-hand or the script or
is this a seven-hander really
yeah so we're making a new version of
magnificent seven what
yeah it's a lot different
well where are you filming we're gonna
film in budapest oh really yeah
see that's where it gets interesting
when you you get more for your money yes
but you got to fly all the actors
right so did you is this one of these
things where you're thinking about
international appeal already and these
seven actors
are gonna be from different parts of the
world yes so you're already playing the
so who who is your person from china
maybe i don't know about that um but
yeah
i mean you know look we the the benefit
of this film is it's not a huge budget
film
um we are fully financed with through
sierra
based on jerry alone so we can hire
the best actors for the job
so i can cast who is the right person
for the part versus trying to cast for
who's worth
trix amount of dollars which gives me a
ton of freedom and
you know i i just i want to make the
movie that i want to make
but is there any pressure from your
producers that hey
if we cast someone from australia if we
cast someone from
thailand or wherever it might be right
that we will that will help play in
those
markets there's not um kelly mccormick
is
uh one of the producers on the film
who's also a producer on deadpool 2.
and she has been so supportive and
everybody has been in recognizing the
benefit of being able to finance this
film
solely on jerry's name alone and the
benefit of that
to be able to hire whoever we want for
these other roles and not
really be driven i mean look if we get
you know matt damon or somebody comes on
board we're going to get more money but
we don't have to go that route which is
super freeing
no totally also uh uh gerald is known
for or jerry has
been he's done a few action things yeah
he's done a couple action things
one or two we did a movie together uh
years ago called gamer
so i know neville dean and taylor yeah
oh yeah dude
love those guys well you also if i'm not
mistaken worked on crank i did
and that movie is batshit crazy crazy i
mean but you have neville dean
on rollerblades yeah like hanging onto a
motorcycle with jason stay them in a
hospital gown
yeah yeah i mean there's no i don't
think there's another filmmaker like
neville dean taylor to be honest
there those guys are amazing and you
know it's funny
it's been great it's been a great career
and it's been a great
um you know
hands-on kind of film school for me to
watch guys like neville dean and taylor
and watch
nicholas refin and watch michael mann
and watch
you know edgar wright and all these
andrew dominic you know
watch these guys and what they do i've
had such
a great opportunity to see
guys who i love their style and i love
that they're making movies for them
sure and to see how that works you know
and and
and to stay true to that as a
as a creative well we also you haven't
even talked about the fact that you did
a little bit on fight club which is
david fincher i [ __ ] love that movie
uh so you and a little bit on panic room
uh
there we go yeah i knew that but let's
get into fight club real quick uh so
what did you do on fight club so fight
club was was
way early in my stunt man days and there
was a scene where guys were rappelling
down the side of a building in downtown
l.a and i think they were spray painting
the face on the side of the building
i think the scene got cut completely so
we were there setting up the repels and
all that it wasn't
it wasn't a whole lot and i didn't i
don't even think david was there
so you should get him for second unit
i'm kidding that'd be crazy i think i
think he's going to be
in january possibly shooting world war
z2 yeah i think so too
yeah i'm pretty confident you know what
i mean um
listen let me let me stop it there and
say uh super congrats i mean we could
have spent
way more time on all these different
films
and uh it's just there's a long uh nice
resume
but i i hope what happens out of all
this is uh people at least recognize
that
second unit is a completely should be
recognized for what it does
yeah second unit i mean you know look
there's just these movies now are so
pressed for time everything's time right
so
it's really hard to get everything you
want
in the amount of time that you have
budgeted so a lot of these guys have to
rely on second unit to get
to get more um yeah i've heard of some
movies that the shoot is 70 days second
unit sometimes it's going 40 45 days
yeah second unit's gonna be massive it's
it's you know again it's a movie
specific thing and director specific and
things like that but well enjoy your
shoot at deadpool and
uh and making your own movie right on
thanks a lot thank you so much for
coming in
really appreciate it yeah it was great